chris bubich who faced the reds once
last year in cincinnati i have a good
feeling for him
and a breaking ball is hit out to
alberto out at second and a double play
and bubic
pulls it together
and gets through it and works around the
lead-off walk and the o2 base hit
nice they have to contend with the on
fire
luis castillo his season-long numbers
from western and southern don't do him
justice
perez deep center field
extension akiyama tracks it down
castillo loves it
[Applause]
oh and a fastball
so he had aquino thinking off speed
blue kc pitch tracks inside part of the
plate that's a good looking pitch you
know sometimes you're going to want to
come in even further
oh
looking looking change up and getting a
fastball it worked against aquino and
naquin to finish off a 1-2-3 second they
have not caught the ball real well in
the ball games he started
hard ground ball to short farmer short
way one indiana first time double play
it's a nice little make up
the giddy up gets castillo out of the
slight jam scoreless a hit or something
now we head back to the top of the order
and jonathan india
india
into right center
taylor back at the wall misses the ball
right through second goes akiyama wave
is on in third
the relay to the plate no shot akiyama
crosses standing
jonathan india sneaks one past michael a
taylor and the reds are on the board one
to nothing joey bottom steps in with
runners on the corners bottom a ground
ball double play in the first
sends that one to left field ben
attendee on the run won't get there
skips past him and off the wall india
scores stevenson given the green light
bottle chugs his way to third stevenson
scores votto all the way to third base
and the reds on top of the royals three
to nothing he gets the same breaking
ball this one a little bit lower and he
just serves it right down the left field
line
so runner at first base with one out and
here's kyle farmer because it didn't
count against you oh farmer bombs this
one deep left center and gone
kyle farmer's second knock of the night
a two-run homer
and the reds up five in kansas city
but they fell to third place the pitch
swing and a miss by ben and tindy and he
is down on strikes
only the second strikeout for castillo
in this ball game
14th most
there's a good one right there
and suddenly castillo
after
not striking out any of the first nine
hitters has struck out three in a row
home of the o2 swinging a miss struck
him out breaking ball down and away
and castillo ends up striking out three
last four outs have all been strikeouts
for castillo
5-0 cincinnati is the royals bat in the
bottom of the fifth two innings the
royals were hitting him hard but
not hard or far enough but michael a
taylor to left field and that is gone to
put the royals on the board
home run michael a taylor number eight
on the year and the royals are on the
board here in the fifth inning now down
five to one
kyle farmer he went deep last time
oh and he turns on it he pulls it down
the left field line into the corner
farmer turns it first he goes into
second standing with a double as he
turns on 99 up guess he showed me
paul was buggy whip
that is hard to do
called third strike
and hernandez struck out two in the
inning
man nice job 97.
that's right on the outside part of the
plate akiyama you got to go here we are
in the seventh again
suarez tonight over three
payoff
suarez turns on it chipped his bat picks
up an rbi
castillano scores a eugenio suarez
continues to connect
he's got a five-game hit streak and five
ribbies in that time lefty c l perez has
a 7.71 era
that'll get away and
answer alberto will be on with a
strikeout wild pitch
[Applause]
strike three call
fastball from cnl perez dispatches of
merefield
i like that bit of emotion from
c l perez because you want him to feel
good about challenging the strike zone
93 out in the outfield experience at the
little radar gun
ben and tendy
on his birthday
gets one over the wall for a two run
home run
needs a hit on their birthday but a
two-run homer
he'll take it
what a pretty swing that was
been intended with his ninth
on his 27th birthday a slider
and he does it against his hometown team
so
there's no two on nobody out
and here's the time run michael a taylor
a little doinker to right field
one run is home
dozier goes to third
and the tying run is at second base with
nobody out
15th heir on the season
right between the wickets he hit it hard
but he just
whipped it nicki is hold for three
two times tonight he hit the ball hard
to the right side and legally taylor
close at second
there it is that'll be a base hit into
left field
taylor is on his way aquino's throw is
high
the royals have tied it and now nikki
lopez will make it to third base
to hit it soft and swing easy and put it
in play
tremendous lift
picked up solaire and the whole team
nikki lopez stays hot
it'll jam lop shots you can't beat that
coinker that's a beauty ties it up with
salvi up there
the reds certainly want to have
three outfielders back out there
salvi hits a line drive left field
aquino is back salvador perez
walks it off
with a dramatic four run bottom of the
ninth inning
how exciting
was that fantastic work offensively
competing to the very end
like manager mike matheny says our guys
never quit they continued to push